hello everybody and welcome to another
tunnel technique class at home I hope
you are all doing fine
so today we are going to work on our
free leg Yeah and the exercises are very
good for men and for women yeah we both
use the same mechanics and the same
language and the same technique when it
comes to our free leg okay if you're a
woman and you want to do these exercises
on high heels that's also fine yeah no
problem today now a few ideas before we
start the best way to understand the
free learning in Davao is as a double
pen to me yeah you have one pendulum on
the hip yeah here that allows you to
move the leg in all directions and you
have another pendulum on the knee that
allows you to move the lower leg only in
this direction yeah and when you combine
both pendulums you can generate all the
movements that you need for download
yeah
combining both pendulums then allows all
the movements elevator now the reason
why you need to work on your freelay on
the quality of the movement of your free
leg is because the free leg is extremely
important expressively in Tango yeah
everyone who watches you dance will look
mostly at your free leg nobody looks
understanding that because the standing
leg only provides support and direction
but the free leg provides much more the
way you move your free leg can Define
for example the style of Tango that you
that you dance depending on which style
of family runs you will use your free
leg differently yeah the three levels
provides the expressivity of your dance
yeah it provides the way you understand
the music your musicality yeah it
provides a way for you to express your
emotion depending on how you do it yeah
how you move the leg let's say that the
Embrace in Tango connects you to the
partner the standing Net Connection to
the floor and the free leg connects you
to the music okay
so your affiliate carries your
musicality your character your emotion
yeah
that's why you have to work a lot on
your free leg the quality of the
movement of your freelance now there is
one concept that for me is very
important about this quality of movement
which is that no matter what you do with
your free leg yeah you should always use
as little Force as possible yeah don't
use Force when you use the free leg Yeah
just use the weight of the leg itself
yeah the way to generate the momentum
for the pendulum yeah if you achieve
that yeah then your movements will look
very relaxed very efficient and very
elegant and pleasing to watch yeah so I
hope that these exercises will help you
start developing that quality okay so
with these ideas in mind let's start
with our one okay warm up so put your
feet together straight posture relax
find your Center relax the arms and we
start with shoulder rotations yeah
remember to them big and slow and keep
your elbows relaxed don't bend them when
you lift the shoulders okay let's do it
eight times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
now we go arm circles yeah remember you
lift both arms at the same time keeping
the elbow straight and the shoulders
down and when you open them to the sides
try to pass your hands a bit behind your
back so that you stretch the chest
muscles okay and then you bring them
down let's do it three times
one
two
three
big and slow
four open the chest
five
six
seven
o straight
and eight okay now we bend the Torso
remember we lift one arm make sure that
the elbow is straight and the arm is
pointing directly up then slide the
other hand down your leg until you can
touch the side of your knee as you
repeat this every week you should be
able to go lower each time yeah then
hold the stretch enjoy it and then use
the hand on top to lift yourself up
slowly to the vertical and then you
repeat to the other side okay let's do
it four times alternating sides
and let's start with the first one one
go down hold the stretch
and one
one to the side
go down touch the knee
hold it
and water
two
go down the leg touch the knee hold the
stretch
go up
and two go down
touch the knee
unblock
three
go down
that's when you hold it
go up
three go down the leg
that's the knee hold
up
four
down
that's the knee
holy time go up and four Go Round the
leg touch the knee hold it
and go up
okay now we open it keep the knees
straight make a circle with your arms
yeah put your hands below the chest
below the chest level not too high and
then turn your torso as much as you can
until you find the limit yeah left and
right but without turning the hip or
without turning the head hip and head
always look forward we only move the
doors okay
let's do it eight times twice to each
side let's go one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight anymore one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay now hands behind your head yeah and
I'll show you from the profile
you are slowly forward with a torso
until your back is parallel with the
floor and then you keep going down until
your head and the Torso is hanging and
you keep your knees straight all the
time yeah and then you bounce three
times one two three and then you start
by moving the hair forward and then you
go up from the head yeah
don't go up from the back like this
because it's a little bit harder yeah do
it from the head okay we do it eight
times
so let's go
one go down slowly take your time
and bouncy dance Bounce Bounce Bounce
start with the head and go up
two go down
bounce bounce bounce
three go down
bounce bounce bounce from the head to up
four go down
bounce bounce bounce and what
five go down keep your knees straight
bounce bounce bounce and walk
six go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
seven go down
bounce bounce bounce means straight and
go up
and the last one eight go down slowly
about about bounce
angle upper okay now the hands go from
the head to the hip
your knees straight and the heels on the
floor all the time and then move your
hip back as if you want to touch the
wall behind you yeah and then move the
hip to the side then in front and then
to the sky other side and into the
initial position
make a big circle with the hip keep your
head more or less in the same position
all the time and keep your knees
straight all the time don't bend them
yeah straight okay will be eight times
to One Direction and eight times to the
other direction
okay let's go one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight and now the other direction One
two
three
four
five
five six
seven
eight
okay now we put our feet together make
sure that your knees and your feet are
really close yeah they are touching each
other okay keep your hands on your hips
if you want and then bend the knees
bounce three times one two three then
stretch the knees go slowly forward and
then go up
until you hold your weight with the ball
and Toes of your feet okay and then go
down slowly control don't go down too
fast okay and we do this eight times
let's go one bounce bounce bounce
stretch the knees go up push the floor
and hold this position
and then down slowly two bounce bounce
bounce
go up push the floor keep your feet
together
and then down three bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it feet together
and down four bounce bounce bounce
stretch the knees go up
hold this position keep the feet
together and down five bounce bounce
bounce
go up
heels together
and uh six bounce bounce bounce
go up hold this position
and go down
seven bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
and go down the last one bounce bounce
bounce
go up push the floor keep the heels
together
and go down slowly yeah this exercise
will give you very strong heels which
are important for the balance in Tango
okay when you have to stand on one leg
you need strong
um ankles yeah this will strengthen your
arms and now because we have worked
quite a lot with this muscle the calf
muscle then we're gonna stretch it
that's the last exercise
so I'll show you from from the profile
you do a big step back behind you yeah
you find your balance in between both
legs 50 50. if you have balanced
problems you can put one finger on a
wall yeah don't lean on the wall just
one finger but if you can
keep your balance without support okay
then make sure that the heel of the foot
that is behind is on the floor
and that the foot is pointed forward not
opening because if you have the food IVs
you won't be able to stretch the calf
muscle properly so the foot has to point
forward okay under the knee is straight
yeah and then bend the forward knee
slowly until you feel a very good
stretch on the curve behind you and then
let's hold this position for 20 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten ten more one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
and ten now we're out of this position
by stretching the front knee slowly and
then let's repeat it to the other side
so big step behind you
find your buttons in the middle put the
back heel on the floor point the foot to
the front
stretch the knee behind you and then
bend the knee forward until you feel uh
the back calf muscles stretching yeah
and then hold it 20 seconds one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten ten more
one
two keeping it straight yeah three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
and ten now stretch the four knee to get
out
relax the legs and we are ready for the
first exercise okay in this first
exercise we will oscillate our free leg
forward and backward like this in a
straight line yeah using only the hip so
we keep the legs straight we don't bend
the knee yeah and we also keep the foot
straight yeah not Flex like this but
straight yeah like this only use a hip
okay now the standing leg should be
straight because if you bend the knee
then you won't have space for the free
leg yes so keep the standing leg
strength as well you have the knee
straight
if you want to work with your posture at
the same time you can hold the stick
above your head with arms straight like
this yeah that's wait for posture as
well and balance if that's too much then
you can do the exercise with your hands
on your hips like this or you can open
your arms to the sides yeah this helps
with balance as well if balance is a
problem you can do this exercise
putting one hand on the wall or grabbing
a chair or a table or some support yeah
that makes the exercise much easier but
the goal should be to do the exercise
only with the support of your standing
leg like that yeah now the priority here
is not to lift your leg as much as you
can like this yeah that's not the
priority the priority is to move your
leg as relaxed as you can yeah you relax
delay as much as you can and you use as
little Force as possible for the
pendulum yeah as little Force as
possible
okay you are using the weight of the leg
to generate momentum to keep the
pendulum going yeah you use the weight
of the leg Yeah and then you need very
little Force if you get used to this way
of moving your leg then your movements
when you dance four steps for allowance
will feel very relaxed very easily they
will take very little effort and
therefore they will be very efficient
and they will look elegant and beautiful
yeah that's the idea okay so now we will
do it together I will do it from the
profile and I will start with my weight
on the left leg Yeah that's my standing
leg and the right leg is towards you and
it will be my free leg and we will do 32
pending rooms yeah four times eight I
will count to eight four times okay so
get ready fit together put the stick
above your head you use it
find your balance put your weight on the
left leg relax the right leg as much as
you can and you start one
two
three
four
five
six seven
eight
one
two three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight okay relax the legs and when you
do the exercise also be careful that you
don't move the Torso forward and
backward when you oscillate the leg that
you don't do this yeah your thoughts
should be straight and you should
isolate the leg at the hip yeah so you
only move the hip and not the Torso if
you use a stick this helps a lot to
prevent movement on the Torso okay so
now let's do it to the other side yeah
so I put my weight on the right leg and
the left leg is towards you this will be
my three legs so relax delay a lot
and then let's do it 32 times together
ah one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great so let's go to the next exercise
okay in this second exercise we will use
the side pendulum yeah this direction we
will open our leg and close it open and
close open and close yeah and the same
tips apply keep your standing legs
straight yeah keep your knees straight
so that you have enough space to work
with the free leg Yeah keep your free
leg relaxed as relaxed as you can and
use as little Force as possible yeah you
only need a little bit of force
initially on the first part of the
movement to lift the leg but to reach
the end of the pendulum and to let it
fall again happens by itself yeah so as
relaxed as you can remember the priority
is not to lift the leg as high as you
can yeah and also as before keep your
torso straight isolate your hip so that
you only move the leg don't do this yeah
if you use a stick above your head like
this the stick will help us to keep your
torso in place yeah so I recommend it if
not use a support or open the arms or
hand your own hips yeah so now I show
you from the front but now we will do it
together with me uh showing you the back
so that we have the same right and the
same left yeah so like before I will
start with my weight on the left leg so
my right leg is a free leg and we will
do it 32 times together yeah I will
count up to eight four times okay so get
ready fit together straight poster if
you use a stick put it above your head
find your balance put the weight on the
left leg relax the right leg Yeah as
much as you can and let's go
one two three four five six
seven eight one
two
three
four five
six
seven eight one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight one
to three
four
five
six seven and eight okay good relax the
legs and now let's change
weight on the right
underneath the free one so fit together
prepare yourself stick up on your head
if you use it wait on the right find
your balance
and let's go let's do it together one
two three four five
six seven eight one two three four
five
six seven eight one two
three
four
five
six
seven eight
one two three four
five five six seven eight okay relax the
legs and we go to the third exercise
okay in the third exercise we will use
this pendulum yeah around the pendulum
on the floor yeah
the pendulum starts here with your three
foot in front of you and then it ends
here with the foot in the back and it
comes back here yeah to the beginning
yeah now the same tips apply keep your
standing legs straight knees straight so
that you have space to work with the
field yeah keep the free leg very
relaxed yeah and use as little Force as
possible you only need a little bit of
force to start each pendulum but then
you use the weight of the leg
to generate the momentum to keep the
pendulum going you see very relaxed now
keep the foot on the floor all the time
yeah don't leave the food like this yeah
later when you dance this is okay for
example when you're a woman and you get
a Sakara here you can let your food uh
fly a little bit above the floor but now
for the exercise keep the foot all the
time on the floor and as relaxed as
possible okay then as before don't move
the Torso when you will depend on
because you will lose the balance if you
use the stick above your head the stick
really helps to keep your torso locked
in place so that it doesn't move yeah
like this okay and those are the tips I
show you from the front but like before
now we will do it with me showing you
the back so we have the same right and
the same left okay so I will start with
my weight on the left the right will be
my free leg and we will do it 32 times
yeah
we count every time that the food
reaches the front yeah so one bomb this
is one repetition yeah and two and three
this is how we count it okay so we will
do it together 32 times I will count up
to eight four times okay so get ready
feet together legs straight if you use a
stick put it above your head
find your balance put your weight on the
left leg and then put your right foot in
front of you yeah
relax the leg
as much as you can
and then let's do 32 times
one
two
three
four and five and six and seven and
eight and one
two and three and four and five and six
and seven and eight and one and two and
three and four and five and six and
seven and eight and one and two and
three and four ah five ah six
ah seven and eight okay relax the legs
and let's do it to the other side yeah
so now I will have my weight on the
right leg and the left leg will be my
free leg for the pendulum Okay so
let's get ready feet together stick
above your head if you use it find your
balance put the weight on top of the
right leg put the left foot in front of
you without weight and with the legs
completely the leg completely relaxed
yeah and let's do it 32 times
and one and two up three and four and
five and six and seven and eight and one
ah two and three and four and five and
six and seven and eight and one ah two
and three ah four and five and six and
seven and eight
ah one up two and three and four and
five ah six and seven and eight
okay great relax the legs okay in these
last exercise we will use the knee yeah
the pendulum of the knee we said that
the leg is a double pendulum because it
has one bedroom on the hip and one
underneath if you use the pendulum of
the hip you can move the whole leg in
all directions yeah because the hip is a
double joint
but if you use the pendulum of the knee
you can only move the lower leg and only
front and back because that's the only
axis that the knee can bend okay that's
it so this would be the exercise you
start with your feet together and your
legs together knees together as well as
you can completely together now you can
bend the knees yeah just standing leg as
well and then you put your weight on one
leg and then keeping your knees together
you use the pendulum of the knee like
this yeah you oscillate your lower leg
the foot goes up back and a bit to the
front yeah like this
yeah anyways bedroom off the knee
now
as before do the movement with as little
Force as you can yeah relax the leg as
much as you can you only need a little
bit of force in the beginning to leave
the food but the rest of the movement
happens just by itself yeah
very relaxed and keep the mix together
yeah because the hip now is not doing
anything okay this is not doing anything
it's ordinary okay so we will do it
together with me showing you from the
profile again yeah now I will start with
my weight on the left leg the right leg
is free and it is the leg towards you
and we will do it 32 times like before I
will count to eight four times okay so
get ready put your feet together if you
use a stick for posture then put it
above your head now bend the knees a
little bit
put your weight on the left
and then relax your right leg and then
let's do it 32 times
and one two three
four
five six seven eight one two three four
five six seven eight yeah remember keep
the knees together and try to isolate
just the lower leg and move it as
relaxed as you can yeah just use the
weight of the lower leg to generate the
momentum for the pendulum yeah so that
we use as little Force as possible let's
do it to the other side fit together
stick above your head weight on the
right leg left leg is relaxed
and bend the knees a little bit okay
let's do it
and one two three four five six seven
eight one two three four five six seven
eight one two three four five
six seven eight okay relax the legs
and that was a series of exercises now I
would recommend that you do the whole
thing again at least twice more okay so
this was the series of excel sessions to
work on the pendulums of your free leg
in isolation yeah one at a time this
will already help your dance a lot but
next time we will combine the pendulums
to generate more complex movements and
you will see how in this way we can
generate practically all the movements
that you need in Tango for your free leg
okay again thank you for the people who
support this channel by subscribing
commenting on the videos liking them and
especially sending donations or booking
private classes with me because that
really helps yeah if you would like to
do those things donate or book private
classes the links are down in the
description below the video okay thank
you very much for watching practice
practice and see you on the next video
bye bye